Бруно Мацца дуже пишається цим футбольним майданчиком.
Тут він тренує дітей з неблагополучних околиць Неаполя.
Багато з них тут уперше дізнаються, що таке повага,
чесні правила та товариська взаємодія.
Цей район - Кайвано - відомий високим безробіттям, насиллям та наркотиками.
Діти вдома все помічають. Вони бачать,
як батько-наркоторговець на столі у вітальні
пакує наркоту для продажу на вулиці.
37-річний Бруно хоче запропонувати цим підліткам
бодай якусь альтернативу в житті.
У цьому невеликому контейнері він облаштував
бюро свого спортивного об’єднання.
Сам Бруно у минулому працював на наркобаронів.
Через це відсидів 11 років у в’язниці.
Його брат помер від передозування.
Тож Бруно прагне, аби підростаюче покоління
не повторювало тих же помилОк.
А це не просто, бо ввечері та вночі на футбольний
майданчик приходять наркозалежні.
Щоранку я мушу прибирати шприци наркоманів, аби
тут взагалі можна було розпочати тренування.
Місцева влада про це не дбає. Ці ймовірно
інфіковані шприци слід ховати від дітей.
Утім, одним лише чистим майданчиком дітям не допоможеш.
У своїх намаганнях щось змінити Бруно сам-на-сам проти мафії.
Нам потрібен генеральний план для цього району і
насамперед нормальні робочі місця для підлітків.
Лише так можна побороти злочинність.
Адже безробіття - це причина усього лиха.
Проти цього лиха протестують і ці молоді неаполітанці.
Майже щодня вони стикаються з вИпадками насилля.
На цій зупинці метро до смерті забили
15-річного підлітка - через мобілку та трохи готівки.
У районах довкола Везувію рівень безробіття сягає понад 50 відсотків.
Молодь не бачить для себе жодних перспектив.
Легка здобич для Каморри - тутешньої мафії.
Так звані бейбі-гангстери або бейбі-боси стають
дедалі молодшими та дедалі брутальнішими.
Отець Алекс працює духівником в одному
з проблемних районів у центрі Неаполя.
Його часто шокує жорстокість багатьох підлітків.
Новою злочинністю тут заправляють ці підлітки.
Вони приїжджають на мотоциклах і вчиняють
шалені перестрілки, навіть посеред білого дня.
Так вони сіють страх та жах.
Перед церквою встановлено пам’ятний камінь.
Джені було лише 17, коли він, повертаючись зі школи,
став жертвою шаленої кулі одного з бейбі-босів.
Це було два роки тому.
Бруно теж пам’ятає той вИпадок.
Обурення громадськості тоді було дуже велике.
Демонстрації, обіцЯнки політиків - але відтоді нічого так і не змінилося.
У нетрях Кайвано і далі процвітає наркоторгівля, і
поліція навіть не наважується втручатися.
На вулицях заправляє мафія.
Наркозалежні з’їжджаються сюди з цілого Неаполя,
аби придбати жадАну дозу.
Саме тому тутешні діти охоче приходять до Бруно -
тут їх завжди почують.
А за грою у футбол можна забути про всі проблеми вдома.
Це відчуття добре пам’ятає 23-річний Луїджі.
Бруно особливо ним пишається.
Луїджі теж колись був у його футбольному об’єднанні.
Саме там зрозумів, що в житті є ще багато інших речей,
аніж гроші наркодилерів.
Коли Бруно повернувся з в’язниці, він розмовляв
з багатьма підлітками в нашому районі.
Спільно творити щось добре - мене це дуже надихнуло
і дало сили знайти свій шлях поза злочинністю.
Нині Луїджі працює в супермаркеті.
Неблагополучний район не хоче покидати.
Прагне радше своїм прикладом демонструвати
іншим підліткам, що альтернатива є.
Це додає наснаги Бруно ще завзятіше плекати своє
спортивне об’єднання, аби цей район Неаполя
не асоціювався в людей лише з мафією та наркотиками.